der neubau des sole bades im
westfälischen werne ist bautechnisch
etwas ganz besonderes es ist
wahrscheinlich das einzige schwimmbad
der republik das zweimal komplett
geplant wurde
denn der erste entwurf ist der stadt zu
teuer es kommt zum streit mit dem
architektenbüro die kommune klopp das
konzept in die tonne was ein haufen geld
kostet satte 630.000 euro muss sie für
pläne zahlen die niemals umgesetzt
wurden
ich finde das ganz furchtbar
das geht einfach nicht dass so viel geld
verschwendet und verschleudert wird das
kann ich nicht nachvollziehen so was
finde ich unter aller sau ganz ehrlich
das schicke neue bad sollte höchstens
14,7 millionen euro kosten samt
exklusiver sauna monatelang arbeiten
stadt und die firma an dem projekt dann
stellt das planungsbüro plötzlich fest
der bau wird viel teurer als gedacht die
stadt kündigt den vertrag aber das büro
weist jede verantwortung weit von sich
am ende landet der streit vor gericht
und die stadt werne muss 630.000 euro
für einen haufen nutzloser pläne zahlen
doch im stadthaus weist man jede schuld
weit von sich
an dieser stelle muss man festhalten
dass wir zu einem zeitpunkt die
reißleine gezogen haben um ein projekt
zu beenden
an dem die kosten aus dem ruder zu
laufen drohten
wir haben allerdings kein bauvorhaben
gehabt ja schon begonnen war so dass wir
noch aus ein planungsverfahren
aussteigen konnten
also alles halb so wild wie werner
bürger können nicht glauben dass sie für
die ganze planlosigkeit auch noch lernen
müssen dass dem bürger hängen werden wir
sollten diesen zahlen so sind wir hier
die kleine logisch es werde aber
demnächst dann bestimmt auch wieder auf
die preise draufgeschlagen
also wenn man das in der freien
wirtschaft wieder als normalbürger
machen würden wir wären schon längst
pleite
die stadt lässt das bad jetzt von einem
neuen planer bauen damit billiger wird
wurde der teure saunabereich gestrichen
dennoch liegt man jetzt schon wieder
zwei millionen euro über dem preis den
das schwimmbad anfänglich kosten sollte
in varna hoffen sie nun inständig dass
nun endlich alles nach plan läuft